Globally,
I think we are not taking advantage of
our ability to create,
um,
multi nation,
multilateral alliances,
I think even on a smaller scale than
nations and we're not doing enough to
combat global warming.
We're not doing enough to educate people
who are incredibly talented in this
world.
We're not doing enough to deliver
healthcare to infants and children and
women who are,
um,
again,
wanting to be enterprising around the
world.
Those are the,
the issues that we're not addressing,
but there's one underlying cause of are
not addressing that,
I believe,
which is not taking advantage of how we
can come together despite our
differences and deliberate and decide to
do good.
We need more institutions that bring us
together in civil but robust ways to do,
to do good in the world
as a great constitutional democracy
should be at the center of the
democracies of the world.
Working multilaterally to bring more
peace and democracy and economic
wellbeing to the Group of Democracies
that are ready,
agree that democracy is a good thing.
And to those non democratic countries
where we can act multilaterally rather
than unilaterally.
We're not doing that.
Were at a depaul in Iraq right now,
I don't have the formula for digging us
out of it,
but when you're in a depo,
you don't keep digging
individually.
We should each use our talents to a lot
with other people,
not necessarily people and ideally not
people who are just like us,
but to ally with other people to do some
good in the world.
That means whether it we should be
educating kids who otherwise wouldn't
get education.
We should be figuring out ways of
decreasing carbon emissions,
if that's what we have the talent and
the opportunity to do.
We should be delivering healthcare,
um,
to people not as individuals,
but as collectivities and not depending
too much on our government for doing it
because a dependence citizenry is asking
for trouble.
We have to take initiatives all over and
I would say first and foremost,
we have to begin locally.
That is the idea that we would know how
to save the world without doing some
good in our own community is a form of
Hubris and it's a form of Hubris that's
brought a lot of damage to the world.